I I don't I'm not quite sure what to
okay he'll just guys
I'm just holding on to him or maybe you
need to get fur
have a Heavenly day
oh there's a really creepy guy overall
[Music]
I can't be this dumb it's not you see
he's gonna do it once it's gonna go
first try what do you bet watch it yeah
because you loosen it
[Applause]
Turkish folk music meter
[Music]
have you seen that show Superstore on
NBC oh God I love it I cannot stop
watching it do you have any idea how
many Missouri Beer Fest I went to
Missouri do you have any idea how many
Missouri beer Fists
and worse well maybe it wasn't then
maybe maybe it was
well maybe it wasn't Bell Rich what if
it was Kirkland
maybe it was kittridge or whatever the
they're called maybe it wasn't them
maybe it Kirkwood Captain Kirk Captain
Kirk Captain well maybe it wasn't
Kirkwood
yes let's cut out the middle or we can
just cut out the middle man okay you
guys need to stop Gary could you take
over from Mateo or we can just cut out
the middleman and have Garrett shovel
the snow well then how am I supposed to
do that I mean we have stem tires
what is happening I'm so sorry you guys
sometimes it's Charming but overall
five percent
you know you had me and you lost me like
that this is why we don't talk
don't don't do that don't ever do that
don't smell my hair as I walk by like
you always do okay
oh gross
must be killing you especially in this
ghetto you look like an old nun
in the all black it just makes you look
shorter and rounder you know compared to
her she looks adorable you just look
like a blob
if the sword loses profits and employees
oh this sorrow loses
lines it's written down though I know it
is
my brain's not working dude apparently
teens are drinking the slush out of this
for these yeah
teens have been drinking the slush out
of these for the alcohol
you can do it who believes in Lauren
and for those of us who don't want to
it's bad it's bad
we got this Mark
they take money straight out of my
account so I don't even have to think if
people are looking you know
if people are looking for a good place
to donate my bank
if folks are looking for a good place to
donate Mike no
if folks are looking for a good place
you did buddy but I just wanted to
Barrel through okay
yeah Daddy likey and we're sure we want
to be a high volume store I I knew it I
knew you couldn't let that go hair
chinch hair chin trivia boobs
I'm not bad I just were drawn that way
okay look we have a lot to do okay
yeah I'm fine I'm fine I just like
inhaled like a cloud of hairspray I just
farted that's what happened
you have a chance to have CEO Neil
penderson in our store sir
you know how crazy those gender reveal
parties go
can I just hit you
it's just
look don't touch it what you touched it
I felt that through my penis
oh no hell
sorry you
again
everything's fine everything's falling
apart I think we need a a pellet
cleanser let's cut
no I smell bacon do you it's probably oh
no what man
squeeze me I'm just saying a wedding
shouldn't be stuck in stodgy old
traditions oh right better to have the
wedding in like a dirty old bar with a
bluegrass band yeah to me that sounds
like a great one
[Laughter]
that's where I got married and what he
just said
my brain Froze that was so funny
[Laughter]
I thought your friends are gonna look
back and go why couldn't we just have a
regular classic wedding
my balls
[Laughter]
oh
design
[Laughter]
City
[Music]
[Laughter]
who cares I care
what's happening man
oh no no no no no no
attention Trump
and is it gonna really
is that what we want oh God
my coverage
that homeless guy moved into his car two
months ago now there's five of them in
there isn't that Sal
he visits he doesn't sleep over
you can say it
come on
peace out my
say it on camera
oh yeah
no no no that's good you're in the
pocket baby wait slap that bass you were
doing great
we should hang out more I think we
should seriously yeah yeah
[Laughter]
let's release this little sweetheart
wait
cool right cut print moving on this
one's for the ladies
[Laughter]
[Music]
you're watching Superstars outtakes
you're really good
[Music]
that's me puking
would you tell me if she did no you
don't deserve your gift
uh
no you don't deserve this gift come on
man
oh what a big man you are oh no Al
Pacino I'm just getting warmed up wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh do I make words with my mouth here no
don't don't try to flip it
it's gonna keep making noises until the
scene's over if if you could make it a
little more uh
if you can make it a little what is the
word
personal
should I even bother
I don't think I've seen something
funnier than that
cut print moving on that's a good night
to everyone